now Brazil is heading for presidential
elections this weekend in which two men
with that magically opposed ideologies
will fight for control of the world's
fourth largest democracy right-wing
populist incumbent Jaya bolsonaro is
facing a strong Challenge from a former
Brazilian president leftist Luis inacio
Lula de Silva Lula has a strong lead in
the polls and could win outright in this
first round of voting we'll take it to
Rio De Janeiro for analysis in just a
moment first though here's a look at the
candidates
a stark choice on the right and coming
jair bolsonaro on the left his
Challenger Luis Ignacio de Silva
bolsonaro has ruled and campaigned as a
guardian of traditional Family Values
famously Macho he enjoys strong support
from Brazil's many Evangelical
Christians
his time in office since 2019 has seen a
sharp increase in the destruction of the
Amazon rainforest which bolsonaro sees
as an under exploited resource
he dismissed the coronavirus pandemic
that killed hundreds of thousands of
Brazilians leading to one of the highest
death tolls in the world
and he's been accused of encouraging
excessive use of force by police as well
as making misogynistic and racist
statements
his rival Luis Ignacio Lula de Silva has
broad-based public support despite
having served jail time for money
laundering and Corruption
a conviction that was later annulled his
fans say that in his two terms as
president government policies lifted
Millions out of poverty
Lula has promised to increase public
spending if he wins make the rich pay
higher taxes and protect the Amazon
rainforest in most polls he has a
comfortable lead in the run-up to the
election but in a move reminiscent of
former U.S president and political Ally
Donald Trump bolsonaro has suggested
that the election will be fraudulent and
that he may refuse to accept defeat
that could plunge Brazil into full-blown
crisis
despite Lula's lead the only thing that
seems sure about the outcome of Sunday's
vote
is that it will be dramatic
well let's join DW's Latin America
correspondent Johan Ramirez in Rio de
Janeiro welcome Johan are we likely to
see a winner in the first round of
voting
it is difficult to forecast what is
going to happen next Sunday I mean if we
see at the polls almost every poll give
an important advantage to leftist
candidates a candidate and former
president Lula da Silva some of the
polls give him even 15 points over
current president jair bolsonaro to win
in the first round any candidates many
of the candidates must obtain at least
50 plus one in order to become president
Paul's gave to Lula around 50 50 49 48
but it's unclear whether or not he is
going to get that 50 plus one in order
to win to have a definitive win on
Sunday at the end of the day not
everybody wants to believe in Paul's
anymore so we had to to wait until
Sunday to see what is going to happen
here in Brazil and our Brazil's
institution strong enough to ensure a
peaceful transfer of power if as is
hinted president bolsonaro rejects a
vote that goes against him
unlike any other countries in Latin
America Brazil is a federal state it
means that the president has less space
less power in order to impose himself on
other institutions or other authorities
in any case Brazilians institutions seem
to be strong enough independent enough
not to follow the president just because
he is the president but I think that
more than the institution the key is
going to be in the armored forces
Behavior bolsonaro has in the last few
months appointed many high-ranking
military officials those are officials
loyal to him and the question is in the
in the face of a potential defeat for
Dragon bolsonaro are they going to
follow to support the president in a
rebellion late but led by bolsonaro or
Aku that's the question more than the
institution the armored forces but in
any case look I'm in front of Copacabana
beach this very famous place and it
looks like a normal day here a Saturday
afternoon in Brazil nothing suggests
that something that big like a coup or a
alien could take place in the next in
the next few days or in the next few
weeks although experts and international
organizations have concern concerns that
democracy could be at stake next Sunday
here in Brazil okay well we've seen a
shift to the left in other South
American countries like Chile and
Colombia are fueled by the economic
Fallout from the coronavirus pandemic
it's a similar a trend in Brazil
yes economy has been at the at the
center of the Electoral campaign there
are other issues such as insecurity the
pandemic corruption but the economy is
at the heart of the political debate the
main concern for Brazilians is how the
next Administration also Narrows
continuity of the coming back of Lula
how the next Administration is going to
solve the everyday problem inflation
rising of energy and fuel prices poverty
inequality unemployment
for those who support Lula they see him
as an as a possibility of a government
based on social issues and they see
Jerry bolsonaro as a failed president
bolsonaro has defended himself saying
that he had he had a very difficult
Administration which is true caused by
the pandemic and that's why he says he
needs four more years in order to offer
solutions to the population and a quick
word about International concerns are we
likely to see any change of policy
towards the deforestation of the Amazon
if Lula wins
Lula has promised that stronger policies
in order to tackle those problems
deforestation illegal mining climate
change during bolsonaro's Administration
illegal mining quadrupled in the country
and even though bosner has said that he
has done more than any other of his
predecessors it shows how polarized our
reviews in this country by just in two
words yes there are there are hopes that
under a potential Lola's Administration
Brazil could fight stronger against
climate change
thank you for that Johan Johann Ramirez
in Rio de Janeiro